اذا هذه صور جديده لغار جديده او بالاحرى
قصف جديد نلاحظ من خلال الصور اثار هذا
القصف وقوته من خلال سحب الدخان الكثيفه
المتصاعده في سماء قطاع غزه نرصدها طبعا
من غلاف قطاع غزه ربما الياس لديه المزيد
حول ما تم استهدافه
الياس بالفعل ازدهار قد تمت هذه الغاره
للتو قبل ثوان معدوده غاره جويه عنيفه
استهدفت المناطق الجنوبيه تحديدا لمدينه
غزه الضواحي الجنوبيه للمدينه وواضح بانها
كانت غاره جويه عنيفه واستخدمت فيها قنابل
من العيار الثقيل على اعتبار ان الانفجار
كان قويا وكبيرا وكما تشاهدين اعمده
الدخان الاسود التي تتصاعد من هذه المنطقه
وكنت احدثه قبل ذلك بقليل عن تحليق كثيف
للطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي في اجواء
المنطقه الشماليه لقطاع غزه وهذه هي نتيجه
ذلك هذا القصف القوي الذي استهدف المناطق
الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه وهذه مناطق حقيقه
ازدهار تتعرض لغارات جويه عنيفه ولقصر
مدفعي شديد في الايام الاخيره لكن واضح
بان هذا الانفجار كبير للغايه وربما لم
نشهد مثله على الاقل في الايام الماضيه
تحديدا في هذه المناطق وهي قريبه جدا
ازدهار حقيقه الى السياج الامني الى
المنطقه الحدوديه وواضح بانها بان
الانفجار هو انفجار قوي وكان ناجما عن
غاره جويه عنيفه للغايه كنت احدثك ازدهار
عن حاله الهدوء التي سادت المناطق
الشماليه لقطاع غزه صباح هذا اليوم وواضح
بانها هذا الهدوء انقلب راسا على عقب نحن
نشاهد في الساعه الاخيره على الاقل تحليق
مكثف للطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي في اجواء
المنطقه الشماليه لقطاع غزه وهنالك
استهدافات عدا هذا الاستهداف الذي نشاهده
معكم الان من منطقه غلاف غزه وحجم
الانفجار الكبير هنالك ايضا استهدافات
عديده في كافه ضواحي مدينه غزه هنالك سحب
الدخان التي تتصاعد من اكثر من موقع واكثر
من مكان ونستطيع ان نسمع حتى من هنا من
منطقه غلاف غزه ازدهار اي حجم الاشتباكات
المسلحه زخات كثيفه ايضا بين الحين والاخر
بالرشاشات من العيار الثقيل
نسمعها في المناطق الشرقيه والمناطق
الشماليه الشرقيه لمدينه غزه وهذا يدلل
على حجم المعارك وحجم التصديات من جانب
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في تلك المنطقه